so this is arlen kundert arlen kundert
from facebook wants to know
are there solar systems of stars what i
mean by this is is there a system with
an upper or a super massive parent star
with orbiting smaller stars but with
smaller stars having planets serving as
moons so each star in the parent system
would have its own sub-solar system and
no dr tyson you can't just say yes we
call them galaxies oh and because you
always want to know where we're from i'm
from reynoldsburg columbus which is in
ohio which first of all thanks for
coming to wright state in dayton ohio
back in march it was awesome to hear you
speak in person please answer my
question
oh my gosh
so you knew i want to know where people
come from i'm always asking you i don't
know it's a facebook exactly
twitter oh it's hilarious so man he's
like covering your ass
all right so thanks and i did give a
talk at
um
in ohio that was that was a fun day that
i spent there uh so
they even took me to one of the local
pubs that's always a thing to do
in a college town absolutely so all
right but i was at like three in the
afternoon
so yeah i hear they had a lot of
drinking problems in ohio uh all right
so the the way it works is uh if you
look at the night sky half of the stars
you see aren't solo stars at all they're
double multiple triple quadruple star
systems really yeah even for example
uh the nearest star to the sun alpha
century yes that's a multiple star
system okay the nearest star in that
star system is called proxima century
that's right right so you can have
multiple star systems if they are far
enough away from one another
then each one could then have its own
planetary system not a problem gotcha
but
if they are too close to one another
as the planet comes around to
backstretch right its gravitational
allegiance can be compromised ah so it
just doesn't know you don't know what do
i belong who's your daddy exactly
i want to go with proxima
but i can't help myself alpha's just so
sexy
so you can't so so you want a system
that's far enough away so that the
orbits are stable and gravitationally
stable it means you're not perturbed by
somebody else tugging on you so yeah you
can have these we haven't discovered
them yet right but uh and in any big
large scale but yeah but it can happen
it definitely can happen oh fascinating
you got it that is awesome okay
i i just love the the fact that we're
going to have a uh a solar system of
soap opera i love it
it's so it's a solar system of sources
it's a solar system of solar systems
you